hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is the show fit well this is
slightly different so what we're doing
today is we've got this amazing
interview with Douglas morrow
which in a few minutes you'll be able to
enjoy for yourself however you might
notice that it's actually a little bit
shorter than our other interviews and
the reason for this is because we got
interrupted by a wave of social justice
warriors who came down break broke down
the door started bringing through
insisted why don't you just tell them
what actually happened
the room was double-booked yeah so what
actually happened is we got the chance
to speak to Douglas at a secret
conference as you'll hear in the
interview and we only had the room for a
certain amount of time so if you feel
like the interview gets cut off at the
point where it starts to get really
interesting we agree with you
nonetheless it's a brilliant interview
I'm sure you'll enjoy it and when you
see it you'll see that we didn't quite
get into everything that we wanted to
talk about but we're very grateful to
Douglas for coming on the show and
hopefully you'll come back and we can
explore some of those other things in
details so with that in mind enjoy the
interview welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
or the subjects they know nothing about
a trigonometry we don't pretend to be
the experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guest this week is a
writer journalist and social commentator
Douglas Murray welcome to trigonometry
good to be with you both before we get
into interview I just have to say to our
viewers you can see we're on location we
were secret conference here in Oxford
and we've had the great opportunity to
speak with Douglas so thank you for
coming on the show that's a great
pleasure you have a lot of kind of hobby
subjects that you often get asked about
and we're gonna try and stay away from
them much as we can but let's start with
the Roger Scruton affair because it's
something that's quite recently
something you've written about you were
heavily involved in affect for anyone
who didn't follow it just tell us what
happened
oh yeah the long and short of it is that
the very distinguished British
philosopher Roger Scruton now in his
mid-70s author of 40 books on a range of
subjects
aesthetics philosophy architecture music
gave an interview to a magazine in the
UK called the New Statesman and the
deputy editor of the New Statesman one
George Eaton misrepresented what had
been said in the interview aligned about
what had been said in the interview and
caused wider Scruton to be fired within
5 hours from the position he held a
non-slip Hendren on an unpaid position
advising a British government crane go
and this may seem all like well I
suppose a lot of people people not
familiar with Scruton or government
quangos may think well so what so what
is that I hold this very old-fashioned
view which is you shouldn't be allowed
to just lie about people and get away
with it and this was one of the most
blatant flagrant examples of somebody
doing that in journalism it can happen
in other fields trades as well but one
of the most flavoring examples I've seen
in my life
was somebody doing that and I knew from
the moment I read the alleged quotes
that they weren't true because I've been
fortunate enough turnovers Scruton for
almost 20 years now and I know that he
doesn't think of the Chinese a people
made up of weird robot automate ins or
something I knew that it was wrong that
this this hack had said this I looked
into it sure enough or as a Scruton
hadn't said that he'd said that the
Chinese Communist Party is trying to
make the Chinese people into automaton
so that's just a lie and we are all I
think sadly for all sorts of political
and other reasons becoming used to a low
standard of truth in public as in
private life but sometimes that comes
right up to your door and you just got
to stop it so I have worked quite hard
every some weeks to expose this scandal
and to try to reverse it and although
Roger Scruton remains sacked from that
government role it's now known and
recognized widely that the news dates
from deputy editor Georgie to lied
misrepresented than contents of the
interview and that this was dishonest
journalism at its worst and so so yes I
am we turned it around a bit and one of
the things in this affair that struck me
particularly was that I think the
journalists in question had tweeted or
put something on his Instagram which he
has a picture of himself
swinging champagne for having achieved
two firing ability by lying about them
yeah this is particularly ugly thing to
do after after getting somebody fired
from their job he had he had George
Eaton had posted this photograph on
Instagram subsequently I removed it but
of him streaking champagnes saying the
feeling you get when you get racists and
homophobes Rocha Scruton fired from his
government position by the way the the
homophobe claim was particularly
interesting because the tape of the
interview which I subsequently acquired
showed that the George Eaton him Sal
said something which by his own lights
would be homophobic the question he put
towards a Scruton was you've been
criticized in the past for saying that
homosexuality is not normal but that's
just a statement of the obvious that's
what George Eaton says Roger Scruton
then says oh well no when I say not
normal normal I mean it's not the norm
in the same way they're having ginger
hair isn't the norm so this journalist
says something that is homophobic and
then it tributes the homophobia to the
person who didn't say something
homophobic who's the target of his smear
campaign so it's a really interesting
lesson I think this happens sometimes in
journalism there are times when you can
just see how the whole wretched hit job
is done and that's what I wanted to do
that's why I wrote a big cover piece in
The Spectator a few weeks ago now called
the anatomy of a hit job because you
know I'm fortunate enough in this
position because I knew the person who
the accusations were being made about
but I mean I've been overwhelmed by
messages since by as you can imagine by
more people than usual saying look
what's happened to me and I've this has
been said about me and so on and so in a
way I think it's resonated with a
slightly wider number of people and
wouldn't normally be the case because I
think we are all we've all been becoming
familiar in recent years with the fact
that the media is not honest with very
basic thing I'm not saying all the media
I'm not saying all germs have some fine
journalists but as as the model of
funding in journalism dies or at least
stumbles very severely it's sort of
hollowed out and I say this as a
journalist myself it's being hollowed
out and in the space of reporting and
having to really stick very carefully
facts there's been this melding
something's been happening
whereby an activist like this guy George
Eaton can go in to try to take out an
interview subject the aim of the
interview is therefore not an interview
it's to do something else and I think
that a lot of people have noticed in
recent years a tendency in television
and in print journalism to move from
doing the thing that you hold yourself
out as doing and to do something else
and once you work out what that
something else is it's very apart for
the other scales for eyes movement
because after that people don't trust
the media again and do you think this is
a problem that arises mainly from the
left or the right as it both enter the
political spectrum
I think I can happen from any end of
this political spectrum I mean who
fooled to pretend the right-wing press
hasn't been able to you know make a run
of things in the past I mean I suppose
one thing is happening is that because
of the age of social media and easier
access to things that that we now have
the opportunity doesn't always work but
you have the opportunity to unravel the
thing in public so it's not just the
case that somebody can stitch somebody
up and then there's no recourse you know
there is now a possibility of showing
people how it's done
which is what I did with the Scruton
tapes and and I think that I think that
an old-style hit job some decades ago
people didn't have the sort of recourse
and you couldn't explain you couldn't
work out how it had happened but I think
it's more prevalent now it's faster but
this is a good side because there is
always a good side to this stuff you can
you can unpack it in public and do you
think that's why there's this widespread
destruction of the media amongst the
ordinary person because I've been quite
shocked I talk to people doing comedy a
lot and a lot of people go yeah I don't
watch a VC anymore I don't watch Sky
News I can't trust them I can't trust
this person in whatever else well
there's lots of reasons for that
and I think it's not just a trust thing
the television news is a very bad way to
absorb news I mean if it grew this I
stopped doing it quite a long time ago
because like rolling news is a very bad
way to get information it's repetitious
it takes far too long to unravel the
information it's trying to give to you
whereas if you click down on a website
and just absorb the headlines and it can
be the front page BBC hubs the website
you just see okay what are the five
things that have happened and you do
that that's 15 seconds whereas if your
which you're watching a rolling news
report you've got you know minutes
minutes wasted so part of this is just
that we are finding better ways to
discover news and to keep up with things
so if I think there's there's that as
well I mean I am struck by the fall-off
in viewing figures and obviously one of
the big developments of our time is the
fact that you can you can do a very prop
what used to be a very prominent news
program and get very few people watching
you can do a podcast maybe even this was
very what do you make of this it seems
to me like in recent years the idea that
rather than addressing people's
arguments we must just attack them as
individuals seems to have taken on a
whole new level and race a xenophobe all
this stuff gets thrown around so much
now that it's only almost feels like
half the country on our racist and
xenophobic according to to the media
which of course has a danger doesn't it
because it means that maybe nobody is
well nobody can be plausibly accused of
it you mean down the line when there are
genuine racists that label won't stick
because people will go what you called
everyone a race yeah yeah I I think
that's already happening by the way mmm
I don't see it having the societal conks
consequences it once had it's like if
everybody's a misogynist it's quite hard
then to unravel or to discover somebody
actually is you know
so yeah we've been having a sort of era
of hyperinflation in terminology there's
no doubt about that and it's noise and
and and I I don't take too much much
less suffering seriously and I think
increasingly people are taking that less
seriously the noise is so deafening as
in the end you just have to step away
from it that's what I do I don't think
people should seek it out at any rate I
think they should try not to add to it
there's always been an aspiration
suddenly ever since the rise of the net
that that we would be able to have
serious conversations across political
lines and I've been struck by what a
failure it has been actually when I
first met Roger Scruton it was because
when I was just out of university I'd
but in my first book which is on
literature and I was taking a turn
towards politics and I one of my first
job my first internship which then the
lowest rung of the paid ladder of paved
journalism was at a website that was
aiming to bring right and left together
18 years ago so now aiming to bring
right and left together where we could
argue out our views not on personalities
or on you know the usual way in which
these things go but on their most
serious grounds to take each other's
arguments as seriously as possible and
of course it was well the first problem
was that I remember as well Scruton who
had identified that I was not on the
Left said to me it's about 40,000
leftists versus nos and I'm saying so it
is actually a fair fight but I remember
that was the guy said you know they
couldn't resist I'm not saying the right
we can do this as well there's not a
left-right point but on that occasion
emphases they couldn't resist I just
wanted to keep throwing people at like
we've got to not allow that argument to
get out we've got to trample that down
and that just is that is the trend I'm
afraid and
I understand it because one way to win
is to pretend that you're not really
playing the game and then play the game
you know and and that's been happening a
lot in the years since but yes I mean we
were always with the whole point of in
the the optimism some people felt in the
era of the internet was you know we can
have face-to-face interactions and we
can respect we've all experienced
Twitter every way but dude this isn't
intimidate or eat acting is it it's just
a way just to shut down debate and
therefore get you make sure that you
have your own views to be heard without
opposition from anybody else possibly
you know just to win I'm surprised by
the way that it works so well
I'm there's an odd thing enough time
where people are people seek virtue
points by suffering as it varies a very
strange thing in our society people used
to admire people for heroism and now
they admire them for suffering so the
more you can claim to have suffered the
more admiration you'll get and the more
you'll be allowed to do face strange
inversion there's all sorts reasons for
it but it means that in the social media
wars and in the political Wars there's
this fascinating thing where people now
boast about the offense they get they
boast about the online abuse you know is
it every day oh I get so much abuse so I
mean does it first of all it doesn't
mean you're right that's a very
important thing to bear in mind just
because you've got a lot of people being
really rude about you does not mean
you're right
doesn't mean they're right either but so
there's this strange auditioning for
respect by being the most insulted
person in the village and it's also very
misrepresented to me take the example of
David Lammy right who called the idea
and Tori's he didn't agree so they were
worse than us worse than not not not
worse than that yes they haven't killed
six million Jews they've killed more
yeah ERG yeah clearly
in david lamby's view yeah exactly and
he said that then he got a bunch of
stuff on twitter somewhere it was
horrific and racist and he then as you
say used ten messages on twitter from
some idiots as a way of legitimizing the
point of view that he made and said well
look this is what I'm talking about
everyone's doing that now yeah I'm
incredibly bordered everybody goes in
public and says oh look what about the
abuse I got well first of all by the way
I mean I don't seek to find how abused I
am on any day it has no interest to me
at all if I started self giggling and
checking what we were said on Twitter
well first of all I wouldn't get any
writing done I wouldn't get any reading
done I wouldn't see my friends and I
wouldn't have a meaningful life so I'd
rather do those things among many others
then be writing Douglas Murray into
Twitter and read what somebody is said
from their mother's basement and but I'm
but you know I could do I just I
wouldn't because it's it doesn't mean
you've won the argument and this a this
appeal by the way there's another thing
which is it makes people first of all it
makes people imbibe some of the
attitudes of their aggresses which i
think you see it people have a bit put
upon that you some people you know have
again it's not what you read about me
online not reading about you online you
know we're not as absorbed about you as
you are about yourself and and and
there's all sorts of personality defects
you can see it causes and i just i also
think that people should be stronger i I
think as you mentioned you yesterday
this conference I I'm I'm worried by
this thing for instance of people who
say that they're opposing anti-semitism
doing it and boasting about how much
abuse they get online for saying that
that they're against anti-semitism and
then you have example they don't a
single anyone out but this sort of this
this appealed the victimhood catches on
you get things like there was a Labour
MP roofs
Smith is it who anyhow she was at a
meeting call Ben about anti-semitism a
couple years ago and there was some
low-grade trade union guy who's a
notorious nutter who stands up a certain
point in the thing and she says
something and he says something about
her that's rude and she says it's
anti-semitic and she leaves a meeting in
tears and then everyone writes these
pieces saying brave Labour MP forced to
leave meeting in tears after
anti-semitism instantly no no that is
not the way to respond to that if you're
sitting at a meeting and I say okay
she's a woman I don't know why that
should mean she can't do this or why
anyone can't do this it doesn't matter
if a man to a woman a woman to a man
woman to a woman man to man if
somebody's gonna go at you for being
Jewish and say something anti-semitic
don't leave a meeting in tears turn
right round to that person and give that
bastard what he deserves but it's like
everybody has imbibed this idea to win
would be to visibly suffer in public no
to win would be to turn it round on the
aggressor and make them lose that would
be the way do you not think that it's
the easy option that what we're going
for now it's far easier to claim that
you're a victim
to cry to walk out to be in tears and to
actually go toe to toe metaphorically
speaking and win an argument sure
very much so well because also if you go
toe to toe you might have change of mind
I mean that's another thing that's the
really important thing about actual
dialogue is the possibility that you'll
change your mind I think there's
something by the way it's something very
insane this brett weinstein was with us
in recent days and brett and his brother
eric on both of him i'm very fond of him
i hugely of both of the political left
you can have a discussion with them
about anything and you know they're not
going to try to pull a fast one on you
ideologically and suddenly make you vote
Hillary Clinton very confident and very
confident so and as so often when I meet
friends like that friends are the left
and others you know I just don't think I
always I wish I wish all conversations
could be like this I wish we could just
talk about what the situation is I wish
the adults could actually get together
in a room and the interesting thing is
though is that if there's even one
person in the room trying to do
something else nobody can do it that's
the thing one of the things I've learned
in recent years has been let me put it
this way like if you were having a
discussion about the theory of evolution
and you were pointing to problems in the
theory of evolution like things we still
don't know how it works you could have
that conversation really fascinatingly
with a load of people at a really high
level but if there was one person there
who was trying to do intelligent design
on you when you weren't looking you
wouldn't be able to have that
conversation because you know somebody
else had some other intent and I think
it's become like that on almost every
issue in our culture we do there are
lots of things we could really do with
talking about but we can't do it because
there's always one person in the room
maybe it not on this occasion but
there's always one person's room who
whose real aim is when you're not
looking to smuggle in some left or right
wing politics or some religion or anti
religion or whatever and there's if
there's just one person playing a
different game the whole game can't be
played
[Music]
well the game we try and play on this
show is actually just to have the guests
and give them an opportunity to say
whatever is that they they find
interesting and we find interesting
unfiltered and obviously the major
issues that you have talked about your
book and and generally that you're known
to many people for these books by the
way I'm sensitive about this yes
occasionally people say oh I've got
another book coming up next in September
and some people say you know your second
book anything like six we authors mind
that I do I know exactly why but I think
it's fair to say that the strange death
of Europe has been a particularly it was
it was it sold more than my book on
Northern Ireland surprising and before I
ask you about that actually the thing I
wanted to ask you is I remember watching
you probably on question time seven or
eight years ago would have been now
probably last time I was invited on and
I'll be honest with you I don't know
whether you have changed though I've
changed but at the time I remember
thinking who is this angry right winger
that they've got on the show and you
strike me as the opposite of that now
and maybe I've moved away from the left
to the center so much that you don't
strike me as quite that right but you
also seem to be quite mellow and you
have a sense of humor knows what's
changed for you well I've always had a
sense of humor I haven't always shown it
maybe you probably have moved ok and I
probably have moved I mean it'd be very
boring if we just assumed positions in
our life and stuck to until the grave I
[Music]
think I think one of the things I mean
I'm I'm 39 now and that's not very old
but it means because I started my career
very early I means I've had some kind of
public profile for twenty years or more
and there are certain things you learn
along the way there are certainly edges
again knocked off for you along the way
I have a friend who once said to me um
do you you must get less nervous with
time with public appearances in
television
and it gets infinitely worse and she
said but why I said because the more you
do it the more you know how many things
can go wrong and how many ways they can
go wrong and I have this with stand-up
comedian friends and others tell me the
same thing actors tell me the same thing
you start off thinking okay I want a
stage and just do my bit and then you
know there are all these things that go
wrong like the curtain doesn't come up
or the you know the prop isn't there and
then you start to get nervous about
nothing so so there but the point is is
that's not only a negative there's also
lots of things you just learned because
you've done it a lot and amines are one
the great things of experience I I think
I've learned what fights are worth
having a witch or not at least to choose
your fights choose and wisely choose
have meaningful ones don't get
unnecessarily bogged down and ones that
that aren't worth going in for I think
on some things I'm probably slightly
more mellow because I've accepted the
catastrophe of where we are and I think
that's worth considering this is what I
was going to ask you because I was
worried that that would be your answer
because the book the the stranger to
Europe it is a book that struck me
simultaneously as being very accurate
and incredibly depressing yes sure and
should have tried writing it and so I I
suspected that one of the reasons that
maybe you come across as more humorous
and more mellow is that you've accepted
there's not much though we're gonna be
able to do about some of the problems
you've identified yeah
some things you can do but you also have
to work out at some point for your own
well-being what it's worth hitting your
head against the wall for and what it
isn't and to some extend also if you've
done what you can I don't feel like I'm
not moving away from you know I'm known
it's not like I'm never going to write
or speak about any of the things I've
written about in recent years but I
you feel that you know once you said it
enough you think I don't want to just
keep saying that and maybe I've said
what I can and issued whatever warnings
I can and analyzed it as well as I can
explain it as well as I can and if that
hasn't done the job then okay and how'd
you come to that decision about what to
speak about because when I look at you
from the outside I think um across
someone is actually quite fearless with
the way you address certain topics but
especially there's certain things people
we will talk about in even with amongst
their friends yes when they know there's
no one around
but do you see but that of course they
are and they're really important how do
you make that decision of this needs to
be discussed and we're not doing it and
I am going to be the person to do it
well I don't have to take you
strategically I think there's several
things one is I don't know you may have
this yourselves but there are something
to just get under your skin and you
can't quite see how it happens or the
order in which they come in the Scruton
one it was already started got under my
skin because this was a terrible lie and
it was being said about a friend and
something I admire so I didn't know
where I was going to have that but that
can happen from in funny ways III think
that a good instinct in general if
anyone who wants to be a writer is to
have an aversion to lies and I I know
you may say that's an awfully
target-rich environment you're talking
about there but there will be some that
will get under your skin more than
others and you won't be able to know you
won't be able to or you least you're in
a very bad position yourself to analyze
what it is that particularly gets under
your skin but there just are things that
you can tolerate more than other things
so yeah
horoscopes don't thrill me but I don't
feel like they're strong enough and
doing enough harm that I need to
campaign against them very much thing
do come across your path and start to
cause harm to things you care about and
lies that affect things you care about
you will so we all let some lies go by
but there will be some which for
instance you know more about than most
other people or maybe anyone else and
you're going to know I've got to correct
that and other things will just be once
you particularly care about and we all
have different orders of priority on
that so I don't think it's strategically
chosen or anything but but you if it is
interesting always to notice what our I
mean most writers are in some way
interested in dogma what are the dogmas
you know there's no point in just being
a writer and firming up dogmas when the
points of writing is to get to truth the
main point and that means identifying
accidentally or deliberately the things
of your day that you're not meant to do
and doing them or at least looking at
them and saying what is it about this
thing that makes it so sacred now I'm
very fond of a quote from HL Mencken who
said that somewhere in the twenties
somewhere that them you know human
progress was only ever achieved not
myself a great fan of the idea of human
progress but spark that for now but it
was only ever achieved by as he says I'm
jolly fellows heaving dead cats into
sanctuaries and going roistering along
the highways of the world and I I've
always wanted to to encourage dead cat
even into sanctuaries and it's so funny
because every era has taboos and every
era has dogmas and religions and it's so
funny when people don't realize that
they are the dogmatists and the
ultra-religious and indeed as we now
have the Puritans they don't realize
they're the Puritans absolutely not and
what do you think is one of the great
lies of our age that we haven't
addressed yet or maybe we just simply
too scared too
I think his whole slew of them I don't
know where to start I mean there's so
many I think over so many presumptions
of our age that I thought don't accept
myself and would run against I I think
there are ones that are causing us
enormous pain it's very interesting if
you look at the tick list of what are
the issues which whenever anyone treads
on them they blow they're blown up they
all have the same thing in common which
is the society is demanding you agree to
something that is it's not it's not
possible to agree to and keep your
self-esteem or at least be able to look
yourself in the mirror so the most
obvious one is everything to do with
gender and sex
that's why trans keeps tripping people
up such a small issue such a small issue
such a minority of a minority issue but
it keeps tripping people up because they
just don't want to say the thing they're
being told to say which is that there is
no difference to men and women and that
we can migrate between the sexes and
that our bodies are like pieces of Lego
you can just stick bits on two and then
if you don't like you can take it off
again people there's that you know
there's something because there's
something demoralizing about agreeing to
lies this is different by the way from
just custom or politeness being decent
to people that we all should aspire to
being polite decent to people but being
are invited to engage in a lie ends up
demoralizing you I I don't if you've
ever you know communist countries that
was one of the things I've often thought
only been to a couple of countries still
trying that wretched experiment but
those who would travel the lot behind
the Iron Curtain or live behind it often
comes on the needless things they were
persuaded to agree to lie about and
people often wondered why why am I being
made to agree to this next implausible
thing and the answer really was
because it will demoralize you further
and it'll make you less willing even
than you were before to think of
yourself as an individual with any worth
so that's the plan and I don't say that
that's organized I just think that it's
it's subtle that people slip into it and
I think in our own society we have to be
really careful I like heretics
I like dissidents I like the people who
say the thing that no one else will say
I admire it and and I think that I think
we have to be very careful as a society
we don't slip into on that issue on
gender on sex sexuality indeed we don't
slip into a sort of a load of untruths
which basically will just demoralize us
because the truth is is energizing you
know that's that's one of the things
such a relief such a relief not to have
to lie no it's true that's why when
you're going to watch a comedy show when
somebody's honest about a particular you
can feel there's an electricity in the
audience yes people lean in there great
well and that's all the comedy is one of
the best tools for this which occurs you
can't not the laugh the laugh of
recognition
you can't stop I mean I like that thing
when audiences laugh and I should have
laughed at that I'll be honest as
comedians we don't like I have yeah I
have certain lines I use which I know
again to cause an audience to laugh and
then do an intake of breath and try to
pretend that in laugh it's a wonderful
feeling I thought you've laid a trap for
them sex and gender what else what else
are we are we refusing to talk about
honestly oh wow
we don't have any basis for a morality
how about that it's a biggie
our whole metaphysical system is in
serious flux and we're pretending it
isn't because we no longer have God
going from belief in God to non belief
in God as a society is one of the
biggest changes that can happen I'm a
non-believer myself but I think it's
very unwise of non-believers to pretend
that it's all just business as usual
very unwise I mean obviously there's an
attempt to have business as usual by
doing human rights right so many rights
look at my rights I want more rights and
these people should have even more
that's what are they based on where they
come from who gives them to you who can
take them away what's the idea of
equality and rights really does that
work I mean there's so much there's so
much in this and we have I think we've
been sort of the subject of my next book
in part I think we've been trying to it
to put a new metaphysics underneath for
society in order to reassure ourselves
that it's business as usual when it
isn't but you know there's just it's
just a whole load of questions you have
to ask down the road for that I I come
across it in occasionally in social
issues as one I've written about a few
times of euthanasia which I'm always
interested in the because it's a very
ugly difficult unpleasant subject and
people have pretty strong views about it
and you can very easily show them this
problem of what happens if you don't
have fixed values even as aspirations or
when for instance you turn everything
into a right and one of the rights
becomes your right to kill yourself like
that's a new right final right last
right again right okay and then you have
people as I've come across in the
Netherlands and Belgium who are
campaigning for the right of children to
have euthanasia Oh
mentally ill they have euthanasia which
happens of course on the continent
happens in Belgium and in the
Netherlands so it's a right to say
you're mentally ill and we completely
respect you and indeed we think the
mental illness is exactly on a par with
physical illness as the British
government currently says it wants to
regard this as being and one of the
great things that we're going to fight
for it's that you can kill yourself with
the state's help at any time Wow I mean
my editor of The Spectator Fraser Nelson
has a really interesting challenge which
I shall pass on because I think it's he
says since every era has its taboos and
no since every ear is doing thing since
every era has always done things that
had just historically you look back you
think that is nuts why did they do that
assume we're doing some things like that
ourselves rather than the first group of
people in history to do nothing nuts
we're and like but there's a identify
them try to identify what they might be
now that like us thinking why did
Victorians use children as chimney
sweeps and you know what are the things
we must be doing things I'm very sure
we're doing things like I can tell you I
mean then what I just given you is one
of course we're doing things that people
gonna look back when we might look back
on in our lifetimes of think what were
we thinking
[Music]
to me one of the things and this is from
an outsider's point of view is this a
situation at universities where
essentially we're censoring people for
their ideas you know and then I see
academics attacking one another you know
that's that's not new academics
attacking each other stop the press I'm
a little I'm a little wary of the campus
Wars was a lots of reasons one is it can
often seem to be a rather rarefied new
issue most people still don't go to
university most people you know are not
you know their lives go on without
reference to the campuses of our
countries so I worry about sometimes
about the overstay I worry not about the
overstating that can't be I've said but
the the over focus on it because I think
just a lot of people in their lives have
exactly the problems that people are
talking about on University campuses
outside of campus and there were no
reference the campus never having been
on a campus so I think the reason why
the university self does matter and I
mean but a second sorry another second
caveat which is also students are you
know not always but be nuts for a long
time with certain issues like our
National Union of Students like when did
anyone think they would be a centrist
sensible body like okay there's some
stupid kids trying some stuff out and
they'll grow up and become Labour Party
MPs but you know so in a way it's it's
dog bites man I think that I think
that's a legitimate complaint it's a
wholly different suspicion to have the
the the the the bit that does matter in
the campus one is a university should be
places for genuine free inquiry where
people follow truths to whatever the end
might be sort of the aspiration of I
think that writers should aspire to as
well when I wrote my book on Bloody
Sunday I
didn't know it would lead me through
conclusion it did but it did because I
discovered what the truth was along the
way and actually it was very
uncomfortable to write at times but you
know if you're interested in pursuing
the truth that's what you'll do and I
think that those of us who would like to
think that universities would remain
places that do that in in the social
sciences as much as in sciences ah it
just doesn't seem like a great a great
biopsy for a society if the place is
where thought is meant to be best
protected from the mob
turns out to be most vulnerable to the
mob or at least very vulnerable to the
mob I find that that that's where we
should be worried about the universities
but I think there's a very simple answer
to that which is that university should
be defunded I see no reason whatsoever
that if a university cannot stand up for
academic freedom that ordinary people in
our country or any other country should
be paying any of their taxes to maintain
these third-rate institutions I think
they should close I see no no no point
in keeping them open I think that in
reality we've probably got too many
universities in this country anyway I
think they've turned into business
models particularly business models
trying to get money from foreign
students who they charge huge sums of
money to to enrich themselves and give
very little care to quite often that's a
big thing that's the thing everywhere
but if there are institutions that
cannot pursue academic freedom then fine
we will not find fun of them and finance
and there's no reason why money should
go to universities forever if they can't
do the one job that we would expect them
to do one of the caverns you made there
was about while these students will grow
up and become labour and peace and this
was one of the arguments that was kind
of thrown against me when I refused to
sign this so as behavioral agreement
bonded they sent me that why are you
picking on these poor students students
always a bit silly they'll grow up and
everything be fine
and my worry with that kind of approach
is that I am not so sure that given the
kind of social justice mania that seems
to have overtaken some of our universe
is that when they grow up and become
Labour MPs and become I judges and
become our lawyers and become our
journalists and authors and writers that
they won't bring intersectionality with
them oh yeah yeah I know they will but
that's already come that's what he come
ahead of that yeah I mean what is what
is one of the most surprising
discoveries for me of recent years with
the discovery that the sort of
intersectionality car crash is not a
campus thing it's it's every corporation
is doing this crap every government
department is doing this crap it's
amazing you know and it's happened very
fast so that way if has already come
ahead of them yes I mean I'm not by any
means saying these people can't and
won't do damage throughout their lives
in new and inventive ways I assume that
by the way a friend of mine always
points out that you should assume the
stupidest contemporary of yours will end
up in the cabinet you should assume that
you should assume the person you last
saw lying in a school playground will
end up being in some important position
in public life the one the one that
you've got to watch out for and his
friends whereas it happened to him was
that somebody he last saw a primary
school cheating in a test turned out to
be his surgeon and he said that was a
very he said it's fine for everything
other than your doctor so yeah if the if
the stupid students become doctors we've
got a problem
but my experience medics of among the
few that have escaped the madness anyhow
know the the specific one of of your
experience of sewers by the way is I
mean that's just that's just one of
these health this is one of these health
tests isn't it because I though these
these things erupted in such strange
ways and in such unpredictable course
sometimes like so as well the
predictable places but the the it's just
it's just as another bad health test you
know but I mean I'm not
one one thing I've learned in recent
years has been that you you've got to be
careful what thinks it has a hold over
you so when if you're gonna do a gig at
so as and you were doing a charity gig
one you so it's not like you had an
enormous desire to go to that awful
campus and amuse people for your own
enormous financial gain but I've noticed
that there are institutions universities
are one of them which when they think
they have something over you then strike
like a scorpion they can't get you until
the moment they think they can they've
got you there you've got a point of
vulnerability like he so wants to come
to so as so a muse are incredibly
unamusing students and now we've got is
this sort of way it goes again I don't
think I mentioned to you yesterday my my
general thought with universities is
like that is that you know it's not I
take the same view of Germaine Greer
takes it's not like an enormous it's not
saying I enormous ly want or seek in my
life to be invited to speak the student
unions at various universities across
this country or America or anywhere else
none of my self esteem relies upon it
none of my sense of self-worth relies
upon it and I don't know that I'll gain
very much myself from doing it so I'm
not likely to put myself in the
situation often of them thinking that I
want that because I don't but if they
think you do and then they will find a
way to punish you for it
and you mentioned about
intersectionality being correct why why
is it what why do you disagree with it
what are the flaws and their dates think
I've actually been reading a lot about
this and I think it should be taken
seriously because
it's on its own lights is a pretty
serious attempt to restructure
everything in brief it's not going to
work and it's not going to work for what
are already very evident reasons
everything runs against everything else
that's one of the biggest ones why is
trans so painful it's painful because it
runs against gay and women just for
starters
just for starters so this idea that you
have different interest groups all of
which you know it's like it's meant to
lock in like this you know once he said
the thing they got from the from the
post war left was that you know there's
a life was of Webb which you had unweave
and but they've got this idea the
interlocking sections of society will go
in like that and then and then we
Nirvana in fact it's all coming in this
horrible angle and as I say the trans
one is an important one because people
haven't worked this out yet I think but
if you take what has been the
presumption of recent decades about what
homosexuality is and that in itself is a
bit of a presumption which I wouldn't go
into now but it's a it's a it's an
interesting presumption it is that gay
people are born this way but the trans
thing says an effeminate young boy might
not grow up to be a gay man but may need
surgical intervention and be turned into
a girl now that is very very
destabilizing for gay men the idea that
a tomboy girl is not going to grow up to
be a heterosexual girl or a happy
healthy lesbian but he's somebody who
could be medically experimented upon to
turn into a male with skin grafts from
the arm to try to create something
similar to a penis
that's very undermining to gay people
very very undermining and that's on a
minority entrepreneur 'ti with women I
mean women have fought and campaigned
and argued for decades to get to the
stage where they have not any equal
rights but are allowed to be not
conforming to what men think women ought
to conform to being and then you get
trans over that what's one of the
striking things about trans that so many
trans male to females behave like dress
like look like parodies of womanhood
that's a really big problem it's very
very offensive to an awful lot of women
who don't think that for instance being
a woman means looking kind of like a
porn star or here's another example one
prominent trans mailed female figure who
was on a panel a little while ago sits
on the panel and gets out her knitting
right when did you last see a woman MIT
in public right so it's like gosh gosh
women are thinking I know they're
telling me it's gonna be that that's
what womanhood is I thought we got past
this so intersection out he was meant to
amend us all it was meant to bring all
of this together all of the injustice is
of the world we're going to be nicely
cohered no no it doesn't work because
the whole thing doesn't fit because it
can't it all runs against each other and
it's a catastrophe already and he's
going to get much much worse we saw that
school in I can remember it's somewhere
up north in Birmingham I think it might
be there was a Muslim school that was
I think they were banning teaching about
homosexuality because that's what the
parents wanted and you could just see
the the radical leftist heads just
exploded because it's an oppressed group
oppressed yet another oppressed group
yes yes that's one I've pointed out a
fair amount in my time it was one of the
first things in the early 2000s that I
noticed so that got me interested in the
Islam thing which was this one's against
other minorities and I'm I'm very struck
by the fact that so many people are now
catching up with that but yes one
minority group plus another does not
equal harmony may equally officers well
particularly in the case of Islam where
a lot of the attitudes that are within
that community and faith are very
strongly against gay people women and
cetera yes all of the all of the studies
suggest that that all of the studies
suggest that there is not that much
simply within the Muslim communities for
homosexuality in fact several studies
shows zero tolerance literally zero but
Muslims in Britain percentage of Muslims
in Britain believing that homicide is
acceptable I'm I'm past you know
pointing this out I've pointed out an
awful lot and I've had an awful lot of
grief for making that observation and my
others personally I'm in a slightly
Marxist way quite pleased that other
people are now meeting these
contradictions because you've been
talking about for a long time it's
vindication feels like that and what
we've we've run out of time sadly
Douglas we could have done this all
afternoon we've always Douglas Lee
wouldn't want to do it's not that big
another big enough yeah we'll put that
underneath this wasn't an honor but
Douglas the question that we always
finish with is what is the one thing
people aren't talking about but we
really should be talking about my next
book okay
which is it'll be out in September
perfect fantastic well as always follow
us at trigger pod on all the social
media Douglas you're on Twitter as well
and pretty active there just remind
everybody I'm at Douglass Camry Douglass
Camry subscribe to YouTube channel click
the belt button next to the subscribe
button and thank you very much we'll see
you in a week's time
absolutely thanks guys bye bye
[Music]
there is the form that you were asked to
I said by signing this contract this is
a UNICEF on campus SOAs right it was
asked to sign an agreement that his
routine would not contain racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia
biphobia transphobia xenophobia
Islamophobia anti-religion anti atheism
I think it ends in quite complicated
mental arithmetic to offset the party
people didn't think they were funny I
think the reality performing autopsies
recovers
you have absolutely no sense of humor
you feel like you just I mean you're
just so paying a bevin outright you know
all right that we got there in the end
you did a good thing by people thematic
needed right as I know gotten each
problem is I haven't got any racist
sexist homophobic jokes never been a
student of university we can't make any
joke about anything if these poor little
local students get upset with drinking
get over yourselves
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
and here in Britain and in America
feeling like they can't say what they
think I really don't know I get it I get
it especially especially the women who
want to become anyone Gareth Bale right
when from talking them to round the tree
the guy left a perfectly good club for
more money everybody feels like we're
we're all kind of under arrest we're all
everything we say can and will be used
against us in the court of public
opinion and can they're coming for the
comedians first because we're we're the
ones that as you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why the stories got the
restless though it has
you
[Music]